Two NATO allies are making completely
opposite claims about the
same 100 year old treaty.
Turkey says Greece broke this treaty so
badly that it legally forfeited ownership
of strategic islands.
Greece says Turkey is rewriting history
to justify territorial aggression.
So I did some digging and read the actual
treaties from 1923 and 1947
that both countries signed
to see which historical narrative the
documents actually support.
What I found might surprise you.
Here are the two
completely different stories.
Turkey's version.
We generously gave these islands to
Greece in 1923 but only on condition they
remained demilitarized.
Greece broke that sacred
promise so the deal is void.
Greece's version.
We liberated these historically Greek
islands from Ottoman rule.
The 1923 treaty simply recognized our
legitimate sovereignty.
Turkey signed it and can't change their
mind a century later.
Both sides point to the exact same
historical documents to
prove completely opposite points.
So let's go back to the beginning and
trace how these islands actually changed
hands throughout history.
Because the story is much more
complicated than either side admits.
For nearly 400 years these islands were
unquestionable Ottoman territory.
When Constantinople fell in 1453 the
Ottoman Empire gradually absorbed
Byzantine Greek islands.
This wasn't conquest of Greek territory.
There was no Greek state.
The islands had Greek speaking Orthodox
Christian populations but they were
Ottoman subjects, not Greek citizens.
This is crucial because it undermines the
modern Greek narrative of
historically Greek islands.
Yes, they were Greek speaking and
culturally Greek but politically they
were Ottoman for four centuries.
Everything changed in 1821.
The Greek war of independence erupted.
For the first time in nearly four
centuries there was a Greek
state making territorial claims.
But which territories could this new
Greek state legitimately claim?
The 1830 London Protocol
created the first Greek state.
But look at the map they drew.
Greece got the Peloponnese, central
Greece and some nearby islands.
That's it.
All those Aegean islands
we're fighting about today?
Still Ottoman.
Crete, the Dodacaneese, the Eastern
Aegean islands all remained
under the Sultan's control.
Greece spent the next 80
years gradually expanding.
The 1881 Convention of Constantinople
gave them tesselli, implementing
recommendations from the
earlier 1878 Treaty of Berlin.
The Balkan Wars of 1912 to 1913 brought
most of the Aegean islands.
But here's what's important.
Each expansion was negotiated and
internationally recognized.
Greece didn't just declare ownership,
they got legal transfers.
By 1913 Greece controlled most Aegean
islands except the
Dodacaneese, which were held by Italy,
and a few strategic
islands near the Turkish coast.
Then World War I changed everything.
Once again.
After World War I
Greece made a massive gamble.
They invaded Anatolia, trying to create a
greater Greece,
stretching across the Aegean.
It was a complete catastrophe.
Turkish forces under Mustafa
Kemal routed the Greek army.
Hundreds of thousands of Greeks fled or
were expelled from Asia Minor.
This brings us to Lausanne in 1923.
Greece had just suffered the worst
military defeat in its modern history.
Turkey had emerged
victorious under new leadership.
So what did the Treaty of Lausanne
actually say about the islands?
Article 12, the decision taken on 13
February 1914 by the
Conference of London regarding
the sovereignty of Greece over the
islands of Lemnos,
Samatres, Mitalene, Chios, Samos
and Nicaria is confirmed.
Notice the word confirmed.
This wasn't Turkey
giving up new territory.
It was acknowledging a decision made 9
years earlier in 1914.
Article 13 added the famous condition.
No naval base and no fortification will
be established in the said islands.
Turkey's modern claim is that this was
still a package deal.
We confirmed your sovereignty, but only
if they stayed demilitarized.
Greece argues you
acknowledged our legal rights.
Conditions don't void
sovereignty transfers.
World War II added one
final piece to this puzzle.
Italy on the losing side controlled the
Dodecanese islands,
Rhodes, Kos and others.
The 1947 Treaty of Paris transferred
these islands to Greece.
But the language was even
stronger about demilitarization.
Article 14, these islands shall be and
shall remain demilitarized.
Turkey points to this as evidence that
demilitarization wasn't optional.
It was fundamental to
the territorial transfers.
Greece responds that this language came
from the allied powers, not from Turkey.
So Turkey can't claim violation of
agreements they didn't even sign.
By 1947 the modern map was complete.
But the legal
arguments were just beginning.
For decades after 1947 both countries
accepted this settlement.
Then came July 15th 1974, a
date that changed everything.
The Greek military junta, yes Greece was
ruled by a military
dictatorship, staged a
coup in Cyprus, overthrowing the elected
president, Archbishop Makarios.
Their goal was a nozis,
uniting Cyprus with Greece.
They installed a puppet government under
Niko Samsung, a notorious extremist.
Five days later on July 20th, Turkish
paratroopers landed on Cyprus at dawn.
Within days the Greek junta collapsed
from the humiliation.
But Turkey wasn't dawn.
In August Turkey launched a second
offensive, seizing 36% of
the island and creating what
became the Turkish Republic of Northern
Cyprus, recognized only by Turkey.
162,000 Greek Cypriots became
refugees in their own country.
Turkey settled 160,000 Turkish citizens
in the occupied territory.
This is when Greece made a fateful
decision about those Aegean islands.
Starting in 1974 Greece began
militarizing the islands that were
supposed to remain demilitarized
under the 1923 and 1947 treaties.
Athens argued this was legitimate
self-defense under
article 51 of the UN Charter.
Turkey had just demonstrated it would use
military force against Greek populations.
Turkey responded by
creating the Aegean army in 1975.
100,000 troops stationed on the Turkish
coast directly facing
the Greek islands equipped
with landing craft.
Greece saw this as preparation for
potential island invasions.
Turkey saw Greek
militarization as treaty violations.
And this is where the
modern legal battle begins.
Does changed circumstances
void all treaty conditions?
The law is genuinely divided on this.
Some say circumstances can
change treaty obligations.
Others say sovereignty
transfers are permanent.
After reading through this entire
history, here's what the
evidence clearly shows.
First, these islands weren't historically
Greek in any political sense.
They were Ottoman for 400 years.
Second, Greece acquired them through
legitimate, internationally recognized
treaties, not through
historical rights, but
through diplomatic negotiations.
Third, the demilitarization conditions
were clearly part of the treaties.
This isn't a Turkish invention.
And then last, whether violating those
conditions void
sovereignty is genuinely disputed in
international law.
Both sides cherry pick from this history.
Turkey emphasizes the conditions while
ignoring the sovereignty transfers.
Greece emphasizes sovereignty while
downplaying the military restrictions.
The historical truth is messier than
either narrative admits.
What this historical deep dive shows is
that both countries are
using selective history
to support modern political goals.
The islands changed hands
multiple times throughout history.
Ottoman rule, gradual Greek acquisition,
negotiated
settlements, treaty conditions.
Neither side can claim
simple historical justice.
This is about power, resources and
strategic positioning disguised as
historical grievance.
If you enjoyed this historical deep dive
that cuts through
political narratives, subscribe
for more myth busting.
And let me know which historical claim
should I tackle next, because
understanding the real
history is the only way to
see through modern propaganda.